speaking of your kids though um is it
true that you had them break a family
rule when the first black panther came
out oh yeah so what was the family rule
they weren't allowed well
you know they're so impressionable yeah
you know and and you you get a lot of
perks and entree and all of that yeah
Hollywood you know being in the business
that we are yeah and it's not for them
yeah but so it's you want them to have
be normal have a normal childhood and
also work hard for the things you know
yeah work hard period like we did yeah
yeah and uh nothing beats that and so we
wouldn't Courtney took it so far like no
we're going to drive them they're not
driving in limos or cars you know to
places to the airport just bring a
regular old little car you know that
sort of thing but when Black Panther
came and just the representation that it
offered we thought it was very important
on the screen superhero you know the
audiences that were there and um and
also just to um you know get a little
love from kids because a lot maybe your
kids are still in love you know still in
awe of you but he doesn't want a hug you
know she's like Mom yeah sometimes
whatever you can to impress them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]